hey what's up guys my name is a Chennai
welcome to episode 33 of game
programming so last time I talked about
making a void tile that is a tile that
sort of goes into I guess that gets used
when there's an error or something
because we don't just want to leave it
blank we don't just want to have like
black thing at the moment we've got
return null in our get tile method which
means that theoretically because this
tile method it returns a tile if that
tile is null obviously that will throw a
nullpointerexception
and the thing with that is you know that
could potentially crash our game if we
don't handle that and the other thing is
we just we never want to be actually
returning null we want to actually have
a type of tile like an actual valid tile
object it gets returned when something
doesn't go according to plan or just to
fill it up so in other words if someone
I don't know if someone gets out of the
map for example we don't really want to
be drawing nothing like some games
actually do um my microphone keeps
falling down um we we don't we don't
want to be doing that what we want to be
doing is if someone this is just one
example by the way if someone gets out
of the map in our game um we want to
draw a specific type of tile because
obviously the map isn't infinite um and
there is a boundary to the map if
someone manages to go above and beyond
that boundary that we pretend presented
with a avoid tile quote-unquote so that
is a tile that actually has nothing
basically no data but again he will have
died I'll just have dummy data okay
think of it that way so let's create
that tile so if we go into our tile
class we've got this public static tile
grass right again we'll do the same
thing but we'll create a void tile out
of it so public static tile void tile
obviously can't call it void because
that's the keyword in Java
we'll just call void tile and we'll set
it equal to new void tile and we'll have
to make a sprite for it which we'll do
in a minute
so let's actually go right now and
create a sprite for it so if we have the
sprite
if we open sprite Java we can assemble a
new a new sprite here and um we don't
actually have to draw a sprite because
I'll sort of get to that in a minute but
we don't actually have to go into
paint.net or any other program open up
our sprite sheet and draw ourselves a
void sprite because again the voids by
it will just be a solid black color at
this point so we can easily do that with
code we don't actually have to draw that
so public static sprite void sprite
equals new sprite and now this current
constructor actually asks for a sprite
shade meaning that the problem with that
is you know that means that it will
actually draw a value from the sprite
sheet as you can see it loads it and it
does all this we don't want it to do
that though right we want to create an
alternate constructor which just simply
wish to simply create a new sprite with
let's just say just creates a sprite
with a color so if we go over here and
type in public
oops public sprite and then let's just
go in size again and we'll go in color
all right simples that and over here umm
well again we'll set size equal to size
and we'll set pixels equal to new int
size times size and then we'll set color
I'm spelling everything everything in
Australian by the way so there you go
color with you um so yeah so now we'll
make a set color method this is actually
adding quite a quite a lot of lines of
code you guys always complain that I
don't add enough lines of code so here
you are
yeah so sack color and sack color will
actually simply fill our pixel array
with a particular color now we actually
need to start to call it something so
we'll just put color as a parameter here
and type int color here so obviously the
input that we put into here will flow
through to our set color and it will
actually be accessible our set color
method so we'll simply use a for-loop
cycle through everything so well in I
equals 0 I is less than the size of our
pixels size I'm sized about pixels so
that way it'll cover everything it'll
cover every single it will cover every
single index of our pixels then because
we've set pixel is equal to we set
pixels equal to new in size some stars
and over here will simply say pixels I
equals our color and that's it that that
is literally how simple it is so over
here now that we've made this new
constructor which does is set color
thing or will do over here is over here
the new sprite will um will type in we
need to specify a size and a color so
the size will be 16 and the color will
be 0 which is black and that that's it
all right if you want if you want to do
why you have to type this alright that
is white so that's the hexadecimal y um
if you guys want to set it to a
particular color or if you actually just
want to make tiles that are specific
colors you can actually go to a website
called color picker calm I'll show you
that website right over here here it is
color picker calm
can do here is you can select any color
you on such as this blue for example you
can copy the hexadecimal that it gives
you this number up here and then you
actually just paste it you just go 0x to
specify that the number that you're
about to give is a hexadecimal and then
you paste in your number and that will
give you avoid tile with that particular
color so we'll just leave us out now but
um that is how we create the sprite for
that and now let's go back into our tile
and then over here
we're where we were creating our voice
I'll we have to specify a sprite of
course so we'll type sprite dots boy
sprite and then let's actually create
this void tile sidebar so I've created
two class it will automatically make it
except tile so we'll just fix this error
by adding the constructor that we need
to add and then finally we can actually
just go back to our brass tile and just
copy and paste this honestly that's how
easy it is so in other words I've added
a random method into um I've added a
random method into our boy toy applause
and it is as simple as just on that in
fact we probably could put
into the superclass right over here um
Bob
go under that now so yeah and again that
will simply render our we've created a
void tile which is just tiled with the
particular color that we'll use for arm
for rendering tiles that basically
shouldn't exist so if we go and over
here into our screen class
sorry into our level class the level dot
Java instead of returning null we can
now return tile dot void tile which is
again obviously a valid object whenever
we actually for some reason don't
satisfy the criteria so yeah so that's
how we use void tiles and you'll be able
to see them in action in the future but
that's the end of this episode so if you
did like the video please the like
button give it a favorite and I'll see
you guys next time good bye
you